hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show now we're going back to the
1970s uh for this one and going back to
talking about some british horror now
this is a movie that i saw as a kid and
i remember
i remembered the title and i remembered
like the particular monster and the way
he kind of like regenerates
making like a big impact on me like the
image of it like stuck in my head so
when i was scrolling through 2b or
amazon prime or whatever this is on both
platforms for free uh i was like oh man
i have to put this one on the list
because i remember really digging this
movie uh i thought it was a hammer movie
it's not but i'll get into that in a
little bit this is the creeping flesh
this actually came out on new year's day
of 1973.
now interestingly as i said this comes
off very much like a hammer movie
although it's more
it's set in the victorian era like late
19th century but it's much more of like
a sci-fi type of story but it also has
like a monster movie type of element as
well so it's more sci-fi more
frankenstein i guess than you know more
a gothic dracula type of story
so this was actually from
tygon
which uh if you'll recall me and tom
talked about uh witchfinder general with
vincent price uh that was also a tag on
production but the guy that directed
this freddie francis who's uh fairly
he's very well known in horror circles
and in just film circles in general he
was the one that directed this now
interestingly he had worked for both
hammer before and for amicus um he
actually directed um let's see for
hammer he did dracula's risen from the
grave in 1968 he did the evil of
frankenstein from 1964 and a couple of
other ones and then he went to work for
amicus in the late 60s early 70s as well
he did tales from the crypt from 1972
the anthology movie which uh is also on
my list because i really really like
that movie uh he also did torture garden
dr tara's house of horrors a bunch of
other ones and then later on like going
into the 80s he started working as a
cinematographer with david lynch he did
the elephant man he did dune he did the
straight story um and he also i believe
won a um an academy award for the movie
glory from 1989
so like i said you know very well
respected dude and he's the one that
directed this movie the creeping flesh
now the awesome thing about this and i
think the reason why a lot of people uh
misperceive it maybe as a hammer film is
because it stars those two
titans of british horror uh christopher
lee and peter cushing and the
interesting thing about this is that i
mean i know christopher lee like plays a
villain a lot um and he's kind of a
villain in this one but
peter cushing's character
he's kind of a little bit i don't know
it's kind of like they're playing with
the type casting like he's sort of
playing against type but not it's almost
kind of like they're
subverting like the regular role that he
plays so it's like a really interesting
i just like i don't know i just really
really like the plot of this and i just
think it's like a really interesting uh
story so what we have uh peter cushing
he plays a professor named emanuel
hildern uh and this is kind of set like
i said in the late like in the 1890s
somewhere around there
now
he has apparently he's kind of like
telling this story to somebody it's like
a little he's telling the story he comes
back from an expedition and he's telling
everybody kind of what he uh what he
found on this expedition and he's like
super jazzed about it so what he's found
he was in new guinea uh in 1894 and he
had found
this really big
humanoid skeleton which i mean like way
bigger than a person and the fact that
it was like older than a neanderthal but
like more advanced than a neanderthal
and he never seen anything like it like
actually i really like uh the look of
the skeleton in this
like it doesn't really look like
a human or and it doesn't really look
like an ape but then it kind of i don't
know it kind of like suggests that but
it's just like really and it's like i
said it's really really big
so he finds this and he's just like you
know this is gonna
all of our theories about evolution it's
gonna like put him on its head and
everything because this one's like so
much more advanced so he's kind of
hoping to get uh this thing uh called
the richter prize which i don't know if
that's a real thing or not it's ten
thousand pounds and you know i guess
scientists are like competing for it
like for best research that year or
whatever so he's like super jazzed about
this um another thing too is that it's
not only
that this skeleton is way more advanced
than neanderthal much bigger even though
it's older
also it has this thing where it's
implied that
it's sort of this
what they had thought was like a
mythological being that like represented
evil and it was just like these giants
that had been buried in the earth and
that were like woken up by rain and
stuff so i'll get into that in a little
bit too but so he comes back to england
with uh the skeleton
and his uh house in the you know in the
meanwhile while he's been gone uh his
household has been run by his daughter
penelope who is a grown woman
but
who he's real uh super protective of
like basically he's been gone a year and
he was just like hey can you like not
leave the house thanks
you know what i mean because he well
they kind of get into and like i said
it's kind of interesting because this
goes a lot into it's not like super
blatant about it but it does kind of go
into
a little bit of a subtext about maybe
like the repression of victorian women
like how they were just expected to stay
home and not go out and engage with
things and how uh you know men try to
protect them from the realities of the
world and things like that there's a lot
of that going on in this so penelope has
been taking care of the household in his
absence but because he was so enthralled
in his work in new guinea uh he i guess
he like forgot to send them any money or
forgot to like sort out and she's had to
like you know fire some of their
servants in the interim i was trying to
like trying to skim
you know scrimp and save to keep the
household together while he was gone
because he didn't really think to take
care of all that before he left
now
again he comes back and it's like he
doesn't seem like
a bad guy he just seems like he's so
into his work that he doesn't really
have a lot of time for
family or anything because penelope is
like hey you know you've been gone a
year wants to come out breakfast with me
and he's just like yeah yeah whatever
i'll just you know and like i said not
mean-spirited but he's just kind of like
so wrapped up in his scientific uh you
know discovery and he's really excited
about it now as soon as he gets back his
half-brother james who's played by
christopher lee
christopher lee's character
runs a mental asylum
and he uh contacts uh peter cushing's
character professor hildern who we'll
just call emanuel
contacts him and said oh hey by the way
your wife who has been in this asylum uh
for a very long time has uh passed away
now this is interesting too because so
the wife had been in the asylum for i
can't even remember how long it was i
guess since penelope was a kid emanuel
had told his daughter penelope that his
mom had died that her mom had died like
a long time ago
but actually she'd been in the
assignment because like he was like i
said he was trying to protect her also
it kind of comes to light that he thinks
that
the mental illness that his wife was
displaying is maybe hereditary and so he
thought that maybe keeping it from
penelope would keep her from going
looney tunes just like the wife did so
it's just a bad situation all around uh
so now emanuel has had to deal with the
fact he's like well you know i've been
telling penelope she was dead this whole
time but actually she was in an asylum
so he's trying to like keep that uh
under wraps or whatever now
interestingly james christopher lee's
character like i said these two are half
brothers so there's a lot of tension
between them because not only does james
run the asylum where this wife has been
and has tried to keep it a secret but
turns out that he's the one with most of
the money and he's the one that's been
funding uh emmanuel's expeditions and at
this point he's like hey uh while you
were gone i wrote a paper about your
wife's mental illness and i'm gonna
submit that for the richter prize which
is the same prize that emanuel is going
for uh so he's like oh and basically by
the way i'm not gonna pay for your
expeditions anymore because i'm gonna go
for the richter prize and get some money
and uh you know you've always been
overshadowing me
your whole life with all your scientific
discoveries so that's gonna stop so
there's this whole uh situation going on
now obviously emmanuel's uh pretty
bummed out about this uh but he goes
back and kind of dives into his work
like usual and finds out uh through uh
and just a random accident that this
skeleton that he has brought back from
new guinea if you spill water on it it
starts to grow skin
um you know just kind of regenerating
and what is actually a very very cool uh
effect
so he gets uh you know pretty excited
about this as as you would and uh the
funniest part about this
the funniest part about this is this is
something that i remembered like from
when i was seeing this
when i was a kid i think i saw it on
like tbs or something so he spills water
like initially on the giant's finger
and it grows uh you know skin and like
flesh and everything and actually what a
really cool uh effect it's like stop
motion or it's like wax melting and they
ran it in reverse or whatever so they do
that and uh so he
pretty much chisels the finger off and
like puts it in you know solution or
whatever to preserve it and it looks
just like a really realistic dildo it's
like just the size and everything
because it's a giant so his finger is
like
like a big dick size
so it's just like it just amused me when
i was like watching it i was just like
because i'm apparently uh 12 years old
so uh so yeah so i just thought that was
really funny
but uh when he looks at this thing's
cells that it is generated
he basically finds out or figures out
somehow that essentially this creature
is like pure evil like in a sense that
it's like organic evil right so it's
like so it's got these things in its
blood that look kind of like little
spider things or whatever and he
determines that these things that are in
its blood
are
the essence of evil
and so
since he figures this out he you know
figures that oh well
if that's actually evil then i can make
a vaccine against evil and i will you
know be i'll get all the nobel prizes
and all the prizes ever because i will
eradicate evil on the earth because you
can cure it like a disease so he starts
working on it so he starts like working
on uh something that will eradicate uh
this evil
these evil cells essentially that are in
this being's bloodstream
and so he starts experimenting on a
monkey poor little monkey in this movie
he just looks like please get me out of
this movie like his poor little face but
yeah so so he uh injects the monkey with
this serum that he's developing and it
seems like it's uh going pretty good
meanwhile penelope the daughter
has discovered uh by going through her
dad's stuff for but i can't remember
like why she
started doing it it's like i don't know
why she waited until he got back so i
don't know i think she found a letter or
something like that that said something
about
her mom being in the asylum or whatever
so she basically like busts into her
dad's study or into her mom's old
bedroom which she's never been allowed
to go into like you know emmanuel kept
it locked up like just as it was when
his wife died or whatever
so uh so penelope busts in there and
she's like what the [ __ ] like my mom's
been alive this whole time my dad's been
lying to me so this massive massive
argument
and then this kind of kills me and this
is what i'm saying where
it's kind of like peter cushing's
character emanuel even though he seems
like a good guy like he just mostly
seems like an absent-minded professor
type of dude he doesn't seem like
mean-spirited he just seems like he's so
wrapped up in his own work and his own
thoughts that he doesn't have a lot of
time for other people like i said he's
not being you know cruel about it he's
just not really thinking about it he's
not in that headspace but at this point
when his daughter gets justifiably upset
that he's been lying to her about his
about her mom being dead this entire
time like she thought you know my my
mom's been dead since i was a kid but
really the the mom's been alive the
whole time she was just in an asylum so
she gets understandably upset about that
which emanuel interprets
as oh [ __ ] penelope is now developing
the same mental illness as my wife had
just as i feared which is very funny and
like i said you know a show that we did
a couple weeks back about women and
mental health uh this kind of ties right
into that whole victorian era anytime a
woman gets like upset or angry or
something like about that they think
that it's like a sign of mental illness
even though like i said she had every
reason to be mad at her dad for lying to
her entire life
but he's like well yeah
she must be flipping out so he gets the
idea
even though he has only tested this
anti-evil serum on one monkey he's like
well i'm gonna inject penelope with it
like without her knowledge like while
she's sleeping and that will protect her
like she you know from evil it will
protect her from going crazy you know
and so that's why he's doing it so like
i said he doesn't his intentions are
good but it's clearly
an idiotic thing to be doing like when
you just have no idea uh what exactly
you're doing but he's so blinded by
wanting to protect her which like i said
understandable but has disastrous
consequences obviously
so
he injects her uh and he's like okay
that'll protect her forever and then
turns out the next day that oops the
monkey that they injected with the serum
previously uh
not so uh not so cool after all he
pretty much like flips his [ __ ] tears
the whole [ __ ] lab up and uh
everything like that so not too long
after that penelope also leaves the
house and basically starts going on a
little bit for rampage uh putting on one
of her mom's red dresses her mom was
like a um
was like a burlesque type dancer uh type
thing and she had like this red dress
she was in show business she knows the
dancer so she puts on her mom's red
dress starts going out to all these kind
of like you know you know divey taverns
[ __ ] around drinking and you know
guys like start hitting on her and she
starts like basically like [ __ ] them
up like you know to me like cutting
their throats and whatnot so uh you know
obviously the cops start going after
this woman who's going around
wreaking havoc at these taverns around
the city meanwhile too there is also
from the asylum uh that christopher
lee's character james runs this uh big
bald dude like escapes uh he was like
the worst dude ever and the two of them
kind of end up
in the same place while they're hiding
out from the cops and penelope ends up
killing him
so she gets taken into custody at which
point she's taken to the asylum and
christopher lee doing a blood test on
her because he knows who it is obviously
uh because it's like his niece hafnis i
guess you know he takes a blood test and
then he's like oh [ __ ] looks like
emanuel
injected her with this serum and it's
like he's experimenting on her and
that's gonna be like really scandalous
if i tell everybody about it
so now he's gonna got some [ __ ] on
emmanuel
so basically he's like well my
experiments aren't really going anywhere
and i still really do want that richter
prize in that 10 000 pounds that comes
with it so he's like i'm just gonna like
type uh emmanuel's research so he sends
one of his henchmen out to steal the
skeleton and he puts penelope in the
mental asylum he's like we're going to
work on this [ __ ] over here so like i
said no there's no good guys in this
really except for like penelope who's
just kind of like a victim of
circumstance pretty much and the monkey
the monkey is also a good guy who's also
a victim of search and circumstance so
now because
james's henchman
he goes to steal the skeleton but he
doesn't know that water regenerates its
flesh
and since it's england uh these they
carry it out and it starts to rain
and uh so the monster the skeleton
basically uh regenerates a whole body
and uh starts going again on a little
bit of a rampage at which point like i
said it's kind of like a monster movie
but the monster movie
aspect doesn't really come into it until
the very very end the monster in this is
actually quite cool um it doesn't look
like i'm hard-pressed to like think of
what it might it it looks like it's made
of like paper mache or wax or something
but it's still there's still something
kind of creepy and eerie about it it
almost has it has like these big eye
holes and then it the the muzzle of it
almost kind of looks like an animal but
i can't really figure out what type of
animal it is and it's big and it's like
wearing this big cloak
that they had on it to try to like hide
it while they were stealing it
so basically it's like it's going on a
rampage whatever now emmanuel uh while
all of this is going on and he's not
really super aware of it but he comes
back home and he's like oh my god the
skeleton's gone and then he sees that
the finger that he had actually
previously thrown into the fire uh
because it's well it's moving and he
starts throwing into the fire because he
freaks out and then at which point like
the monster comes there and is like
hey uh where's my where's that finger i
kind of need that and then like he's
like you know and uh you know so the
monster's like well i'm just gonna take
your finger then but he leaves him alive
now
interestingly
this has a kind of a twist ending
which a lot of people don't like but i
thought it was kind of cool because like
i said and this is kind of going back to
what i was saying before about this
being a little bit i don't know how much
of a departure it is or how much like
playing against type it is but i really
like that they kind of did this because
at the very end
um you know all of this crazy [ __ ] has
gone on with this like regenerating
giant skeleton or whatever and uh you
know penelope like losing her [ __ ] and
like killing multiple people
because of this serum and all this other
kind of stuff but it turns out like
there's a scene at the very end
where
you're led to believe that
emmanuel peter cushing's character
was maybe crazy this whole time and just
made up this whole story because
at the end there's a scene in the mental
asylum
that christopher lee's character james
owns and basically a manual is in a cell
and at first it looks like a laboratory
like there's all this look like
laboratory mad scientist kind of
equipment in there but then when they
cut away and then they cut back it's
empty
and james is like explaining to somebody
else he's like
he's like yeah he's been like this for a
long time it's like he thinks he's a
scientist he thinks he's doing this that
the other uh he thinks this other woman
that's a patient there is his daughter
uh he thinks i'm his brother uh you know
he's like so it's very common for all of
these patients in here to kind of like
fixate on me because i'm like an
authority figure and all this other kind
of stuff so at the end like i said i
don't know like i know some people
didn't really like the ending because
they thought it like negated the whole
movie like oh it was all a dream like
not necessarily but it was all like the
rantings of a madman but then the thing
about it is that they kind of leave it
ambiguous where
it could be
that emanuel was put into the mental
asylum after the events of the movie
like that really happened but now james
is trying to like cover his own ass by
like telling everybody hey i don't know
any of these people and he's just making
[ __ ] up he's just a crazy person so we
could like go either way but honestly i
really really kind of liked that ending
like i said i like ambiguous endings and
i don't think it takes anything away
from the movie as a whole it being you
know it could have happened it could
have not happened i don't know i really
like that anyway
but yeah this one i feel like this movie
i liked it much better because i
remember liking it when i was a kid i
saw this probably like 30 years ago at
least um or more
no it was probably i'm sure it was
probably like even longer than that i
was probably like 10 years old which is
way more than 30 years ago so yeah so i
remembered seeing it and like i said um
the the title had really stuck with me
and a lot of images particularly the
images of like the monster's face and
like the finger that the finger dick and
all that uh it really kind of like stuck
with me and the you know the the idea of
the skin like regenerating over these
big giant bones the idea of evil being
like a virus that you could or like a
disease that you could inoculate people
against a really a cool idea
so i really like i really liked
revisiting this one because it was like
way better and there was a lot more
going on in it than i remember like i
said it's almost kind of like it kind of
delves into
the you know the whole the meaning of
evil thing and it delves into like you
know the state of you know women in
victorian england like the whole like
mental asylum thing and i just really
really liked that sci-fi aspect of it
and i really like kind of the but i
don't want to go so far to see like
social commentary because it's not
really that it's more like a subtext but
i had forgotten you know or i didn't
even realize that all of that stuff was
in there
so it's like it was really cool to
revisit it like i said if this is if
you're really into like hammer movies or
amicus or you know british horror from
this time period i feel like this one
really kind of gets swept under the rug
a lot um i even looked on youtube for
other reviews of it i found like maybe
two other reviews of it that were like
really short they were like five or six
minutes long and i was like that's
really a shame because i mean
you you would think even though this is
tygon but like i said witchfinder
general is tygon too and that one is a
lot more uh well-known i feel like even
though this movie is nothing like that
but i just feel like any movie that is
like a sci-fi monster movie that has
peter cushing and christopher lee in it
you'd think would actually have more
uh attention or get more people talking
about it especially one is like actually
quite cool is this one like i said one
with like a lot of really cool ideas a
lot of stuff going on in there it's not
a perfect movie you know nothing is like
you know little parts of it are kind of
slow and stuff but
honestly it didn't really bother me um i
really liked the look of the monster
there was like some really great creepy
shots uh you know of this big huge
monster that looked like a i don't even
know what then what the hell it just it
looked like
no other monster you because it almost
looked like a little bit misshapen or
almost kind of like a melted
candle type of or like somebody that was
making a wax sculpture that wasn't a
very good sculptor it kind of looked
like that that's that's pretty that's
pretty much what i'm uh driving at but
yeah so i just really like the look of
the monster and the whole idea of it so
like i said if you really like hammer or
amicus or something like that and you
haven't really seen this one because
like i said i feel like it's a little
bit underrated a little not talked about
all that much and people maybe forgot
about it then definitely go check this
one out you know one afternoon it's like
a really cool
it's a cool little flick i just really
really like uh christopher lee being
like this very stern
kind of
he's kind of a stern jerk
type character and peter cushing being
like the absent-minder professor who
also might be a crazy person it's seeing
the two of them together is always a
good time and uh so yeah i really dig
this movie and
you know i i feel like it doesn't get
talked about so everybody go watch it
and like let me know what you think
about it like i said it's on 2b for free
uh it's on amazon prime too although i
can't remember if it's free or if it's
not if it's not free it's like cheap
it's for like 2.99 or something like
that but they have it on 2b for free if
you want to watch it and you don't have
amazon prime so definitely go check it
out and let me know what you think about
it in the comments and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye